you know if somebody pulls a gun out on
me
which has happened it's me it's my
family not you
you've lost your ability to use that use
of force
ramp and we're going straight to deadly
force policing has been a significant
topic for
ages from rodney king to defunding the
police to briana taylor and george floyd
we are in a moment where we are
examining how laws are enforced and when
they are broken
how we are treated these are topics and
issues that we don't often get a chance
to hear cops speak on themselves
when watching this video please remember
that these officers are speaking from
their own personal beliefs
and drawing from their own experiences
seek out experts
do your own research and have empathy
[Music]
my name is evan uh five years old here
in washington dc
um born and raised in washington dc as
well
28. what's up everybody my name is phil
i'm in
long beach california i've been a cop
for 20 years and uh
44 years old ben uh i'm actually in
canada right now
i live in born and raised in toronto
been a police officer for six years with
uh
two different departments and uh before
that i was in the
canadian army for nine years i'm
marcellus um
from detroit michigan i've been working
with detroit police department for five
years
currently 23. i'm uh i'm zach i'm from
montana
born in san francisco california i've
been a police officer for four years
i'm 28. hi i'm kendra i've been in law
enforcement
for 16 years just uh medically retired
and i'm not even gonna say my age
[Music]
[Laughter]
i feel threatened when i hear defund
the police phil
disagree marcellus disagree
evan strongly disagree kendra
somewhat disagree ben mercury zach
i really agree detroit public schools is
horrible
our housing is horrible the um mental
facilities
awful it could be a lot better and the
money can go elsewhere
if we can help our people before they
get to the point where the police need
to be involved
there won't need to be that much
negative police
interaction not saying all police
interaction is negative yes defend the
police
because it's not about us it's about
really really
reallocating the funds into services and
institutions
people need to be decent human beings
and it's really about making the world
more equitable for other communities so
they don't even need the police
i don't know if i feel threatened by it
i just sort of feel like pissed off when
i hear it yeah because if you defund the
police there's no training you're not
gonna
you don't get the response times that
you want um and it all started over you
know
statistically since 2015 we've had since
2000 or
up until now there's been about a
thousand
people a year officers have killed and
that's going
off the statistics of 8 million to about
10 million interactions
with people it just i take it a little
personal for someone that just takes
such pride in
not holding any bias on any race or
anyone treat everyone the same
why does that have to come out of the
police why did the police have to be
defunded
i'm just just because of the main like
media blowing up these interactions with
people
well i think a lot of times you know the
default
to any kind of sociological issue in
america is always
the police it's always incarceration
you know that's why you know we're
starting to look at you know even you
look at the
school-to-prison pipeline you know you
look at homelessness you look at
mental illness you look at all these
certain things where
it's just like if we invest in these
institutions more
and that everyone who's involved these
institutions get the adequate services
they won't need the police they won't
need to be locked up i mean i think the
theory is great like refunding it into
like the school systems and they get
this great education and they come out
you know excellent citizens but that's
just not the case
with people there's been people that
grew up poor
in poverty that grew up to be doctors or
professional athletes or
businessmen and there's been people that
had great families went to a private
school and
why don't it be in a piece of i mean you
just can't predict what people are going
to do
you're always going to need police
there's always going to be
that chaos and craziness that is just
an evil that's just kind of bred into
the world there always
there has to be someone to tell you you
can't do that
and if you do that there's consequences
but i don't think the peace comes from
controlling people and telling them no
you can't do this no you can't go there
no you can't act this way you know you
can't be this way
i don't think the world needs the police
to tell them how to behave
people know how to behave
[Laughter]
of course people aren't perfect and
people people break laws of course
you know but this is like why is the
why is it the police that has to come
and step forward why can't it be the
community why can't it be that whole
saying of
the village raises the child you know
policing without police
i'm all down for it the problem is we
are so
disbanded from each other i live in a
really large city here in southern
california
and i'll tell you my neighbors they're
great but neighbor a block away don't
even know his name
so how do we have that neighbor a block
away be the police
of my family which my values are
different your values are different it's
just
you need that level of law enforcement
to have that
that sanctity of law and order i love
the idea evan it's just not reality
anymore
we're too big we're too big of a world
i have the right to use my gun if i feel
i am in danger
phil i agree kind of marcellus
kendra agree ben agree
zach agree you know if somebody pulls a
gun out on me
which has happened it's me it's my
family not you
uh you've you've lost your you've lost
your ability to use that use of force
ramp and we're going straight to deadly
force and there's no excuse for it
yeah i agree um i don't think anybody's
really debating whether you should meet
a gun with
a gun or a knife with a gun but how many
times have we heard
the the defense that i was in fear for
my life
and that's a very very subjective
statement and we've seen people
use their guns whenever they were in
fear for their lives where
no weapon was being used
so let's look at it like that sometimes
you know yeah i just it's a very broad
question and there's so many scenarios
you could do
like with that like what you're saying
like i was improving my safety i'm
thinking more like a guy
that's kind of not listening to orders
and fumbling around and is
in his car he has maybe like a minor
warrant and the guy just
shoots him run back to your car or
something like disengage
um but yeah i see where you're where
you're coming from in that sense
using your firearm doesn't necessarily
mean
firing it well i was chasing a guy with
a gun visibly
very visibly in his hand chasing him
around this building
and i finally see him throw the gun over
his shoulder and drop it and on my body
camera you can hear me say thank god
and i re-holstered and i would go back
to my taser as i'm chasing them
sometimes it just comes down to i may
need it
do you feel like you guys could do your
jobs without
a gun i ain't going to certain calls
without a gun no no
no give me a host i'll be a fireman but
i ain't going to do it
if i'm a cop i'm going to need some iron
it's just that's what it is because
we can't call it everything of course
not i need my gun for this job i
wouldn't do it without it because
everyone has guns in canada we have what
we call special constables and special
constables are essentially sworn peace
officers
but they're unarmed and they do anything
everything from
court security to um policing some of
our community housing here in toronto
but they wind up calling us who are
armed because they can't deal with those
certain situations as
as phil or myself was talking about it i
have broken the law phil
agree marcellus agree evan
wrongly agree kendra marie ben
gray zach agree
[Music]
me mom boys at the high school we used
to go jump on a moving train
um i remember one time we got caught by
um the railroad police
and they defense so i thought we were
all about to get arrested he just
had a little stern talking too and i was
18 and me and my buddies are out thought
it'd be fun to
smash the mailboxes so we did and got
caught
when i was 19 years old i was arrested
for uh
possession of marijuana just wrong time
wrong place
um in an area that i should have been in
i broke the law
so i got arrested for it definitely what
has given me my empathy
towards um individuals that we do arrest
i know how being arrested and
how that charge sticks with you for your
whole entire
life instead of taking most people six
five months to you know get on the force
it took me almost a year and a half so i
have to appeal this
appeal that it just takes a long time to
prove that
you aren't a bad individual just because
you were arrested i have feared for my
life
on the job phil
strongly agree marcellus three evan
agree kendra rawlings agree
ben finally agree zach finally agree
without disclosing where i work this
happened last year in the summer time
big case here in canada actually in the
united states actually worldwide
we get the call our guns are out and
there's no answer at the door
so we start clearing the basement and we
don't know if he's got a gun
or a knife all we know is that you know
there's babies in tenants
so we're going down it was me my
sergeant and
our partner were going down the stairs
and uh
honestly god like i i was so
terrified like i didn't know if the guy
was going to come out around the corner
with a knife or
start shooting at me we finally made
contact with the guy
and um
yeah still haunts me today we found his
entire family upstairs
on the ground dead and um
i've never been more terrified in my
life than
clearing that house because
i just didn't know i thought i literally
thought i was going to die that day
i was on a swat call out with the guy
who uh patrol responded
for a warrant for child porn in essence
about
a six hour standoff we finally decided
we're going to charge the door
and go in and get the guy he had popped
off a couple rounds off of his balcony
shot one over the sniper's head
and like ben talks about still gives me
chills to this day
uh it's not easy to think about but when
we blew the charge on the door
i was the first guy through the the door
with a shield and as soon as that door
swung open and we pushed through
we were six feet from each other with
the handguns right at each other's faces
so it was it was that whole emotion of
it's not going to be me you know and so
i knew right then and there that that
we were going to end up in a shooting
and sure is not we we did
um and so when we talk about are you
scared or have you ever been scared
absolutely and i think people forget
about that like we're human
um and even that was 15 years ago and i
still think about it
it's tough it's tough uh even living
with the fact that you killed somebody
even though you were
justified doing it um it's not something
easy to live with
six years ago i was involved in a ois or
officer-involved shooting
regular call at a motel my partner and i
we get there
come in contact with them we're like hey
you know he was on the second floor
well as soon as we get downstairs fight
fight starts me and my partner we're
both trying to fight this guy
and he's able to get away from my grasp
i
tase him taser doesn't work he's able to
get to his truck
he's able to get the key in into the
ignition
puts it in reverse the door hits my
partner knocks her unconscious
i still have him in a headlock and
i'm running alongside the truck i can't
keep my grasp anymore
and i fall face forward i try to roll
out of
of the way and he runs over me literally
runs over me with his truck um as i'm
looking underneath the truck
undercarriage all i think about is my
daughter
and thinking this is it but phil just
like you said just
that ptsd that constant i mean this was
six years ago and it still
still haunts me sometimes you know all
the
the surgeries that i've had and
everything to to try to restore
my body you know nothing nothing
can take away the mental part of it
george floyd's death was justified
phil strongly disagree marcellus
i strongly disagree with evan wrongly
disagree
kendra wrongly disagree ben
strongly disagree zach strongly disagree
you don't put your your knee on nobody's
neck especially
in a minus um a guy that's in cuffs at
one point they had um
george ford in the back of the car i
don't know why they just didn't um
shut the door but they pulled him back
out and then that's
when everything took a turn for the
worse people say i need to see the
details this
the evidence that nah he'd have to die
there are many other options i have yet
to meet any officer that
would even remotely agree that
that should have happened i have yet to
meet one
two were like field training by the
other two guys i don't care if you're a
rook or whatever
say hey fto whatever get off his neck
if that was me i'm a ravens fan i would
have ray lewis tackled him
on the ground and after you see that of
course every cop everywhere just
i don't know about you guys get that pin
your stomach like
this like it's going to reflect on all
of us all 800
900 thousand police officers i know in
canada recently the
whole topic of body cameras has just
reappeared sorry forgive my ignorance
but i'm
assuming all of you guys wear body
cameras um
in canada that's not a thing right there
are certain departments that
don't even have in-car camera now this
now because of george floyd now the
whole shift has
has reignited that uh the discussion
about body counters and
i've i've heard people who have quite 25
years on and say oh
you know they're putting this body
camera on me not gonna watch my phone
say i'm like
no you don't just as long as you do your
job correctly and that's
all it is and if there is one thing that
is good about this
is we're finally talking about the big
elephant in the room right we're talking
about
how do we make our own peers our own
subordinates our own
uh superiors talk about it you know
and rodney king happened in what 94
93 i think it was and it sprinkled right
we sprinkle it we talk about it still
plays in our use of force videos don't
do this right but
nothing has ever been addressed the way
it's being addressed right now
and so that that is refreshing and i'm
just curious like why is it happening
now
like this this isn't new you know
like it's we have over 130 years of data
that shows that the police are out here
abusing the individuals
killing them so why is this conversation
just finally happening now
why are we finally starting to
acknowledge the
elephant in the room is it because you
know it was a covid
is it because you know the video footage
because it was so in your face and it
was
it was it was time and i hate to say
that it wasn't time
ten years ago it wasn't time five years
ago our job is to make it now
and to fix it now and so man let's let's
go offline and figure it out
i'm pumped i understand
why people say all cops are bastards
phil strongly disagree marcellus
disagree
evan i strongly agree kendra i would
agree
ben would agree zach some would agree
cops can be jerks plain and simple
i mean cops could be [ __ ] sometimes
it's
their nature it's their character
sometimes it can just be a tough day
officers go from call to call and
sometimes you can just
have came from a call that
where you know you had to tell someone
that their loved one died or you
responded to an overdose or god forbid
you just saw a child you know at death
and now you have to respond to another
call you're not going to be all happy
and chipper and
so i can i can somewhat agree
i said strongly disagree i can
understand somebody feeling that way
but it's become so cliche now i
understand that my uniform my badge my
patches everything that you see
represents that but don't forget that
i'm still
a person and some of the things that you
may even say i agree with
but that's tough i'm not going to say
that
poor us police officers right because we
signed up for this crap
we did but at some point we got to say
enough
with the name calling and let's figure
this out yeah
i strongly agree um and i strongly
understand
because i'm for one i'm black and i know
what the
police and the government has done to
black communities to oppress them
and i strongly understand why
disenfranchised groups
feel the way they feel about the whole
whole barrel
of law enforcement yeah i just somewhat
agree i get
um i don't think all cops are bastards i
think that terminology is just
laughable to me but i think they're
talking about like more like the system
and how they think it's like system that
they say systematically racist and like
we're part of it so we're automatically
bastards
is what i've researched about it but i
evan i had a question for you so since
you keep bringing up like the
look where policing came from and look
what happened during the martin luther
kingdom
don't you wouldn't you say that policing
today
from in the past has gotten better
it's changed but
you don't think it's gotten better at
all down to now
yeah so of course blatant discrimination
and violence against certain groups
isn't happening
well not at a widespread level as much
anymore
but it's definitely moving in uh the
right direction i believe
it's definitely changing of course it
isn't the same brutal brutal
institution it used to be but it's
getting better
obviously i'm white so i don't know what
people go through but my colleagues i
can never i've never seen a bad police
officer
but i was just kind of curious your
thoughts of how it how it's progressed
through the years since you know from
slavery to martin luther king to king
days until now
yeah i think it's definitely gotten
better but you know the washington post
says i'm
on average for the past couple years
police are killing almost 1100 people
per year you know and like it's a lot of
the visuals
you know and i think we should really
work on not killing anyone
i know but it's so broad because you
don't know what what
led to that like what situation they
were in yeah it's prince broad but you
know
you know i think it's definitely we're
moving in the right direction
we're contacting people we have eight
million contacts here i mean obviously
sometimes
it's gonna go down but
i have felt ashamed to be a cop
phil strongly disagree marcellus
disagree evan agree
kendra only disagree ben
someone agree zach wrongly disagree
i don't go wearing you know i'm a cop
t-shirt anywhere i don't have an
office with all my accolades behind me
but uh i am
i'm truly thankful for everything this
job has brought me both mentally and
physically
i disagree i've never been ashamed thing
is about me i never really wanted to be
a cop i want to make video games but
college wasn't it for me betrayed i
needed a high school diploma and license
and i had all that and i really need
some money
graduated from the academy made some
mess some great people
family and i've been working five years
now
and the job is one actually i'm gonna
change my answer to disagree uh there
was a point
uh in my career uh this is
due to ptsd where i kind of looked
myself in the mirror and basically asked
myself what the [ __ ] i was doing but
got through that and i can say that i
actually love this job
i love this job it was a great
profession very very honorable
profession but it wasn't until i had
that looking into the mirrors
um situation where i actually started
going to grad school
started doing my own research learning
and actually learned about the history
of policing
and the effects that it's caused
different disenfranchised groups that
you really start to wake up and really
understand
where policing has come from i'm hopeful
that we're going in the right direction
i'm faithful that we're going to turn
this thing around and
we're going to make this profession an
honorable profession
but just really acknowledging just the
harm that policing has caused
certain communities it's heartbreaking
i love the job i mean unfortunately i
had to medically retire
um but i still work at a police
police academy as a drill instructor
i even teach criminal just so i mean i'm
still involved
and i mean i i love it i i love it i'm
saying it's the greatest show on earth
and you get to meet some great people
and you get to
you're actually i think all you agree
you're kind of
built for this or like born to do this
job i don't know i wanted to do this
while i was
in college i needed to pick a major i
got a scholarship for baseball and they
needed to pick
said it was something new every day
tried criminal justice studying it where
it came from what policing is
immediately fell in love with it and i
would not do anything else
love it thank you all for your service
well thank you
thank you
[Music]
you